in all but name she's a member of the
Murdoch dynasty and Rebecca Brooks's
rise through News International later
one of Rupert Murdoch's closest allies
but her talents in making news ended
when she became one of the biggest ever
news stories and now the biggest single
casualty of the phone hacking scandal
her position looks shaky when last
Friday she told staff at news of the
world the paper was ending this is not
exactly the best time in my life but I'm
determined to get ever since many have
called for her to go angry so many lost
their jobs while she remained in post
how do you see the bigger picture advise
your actions yesterday you're making a
whole of news international toxic Miami
concern you think we've got to work for
you again as well Rebekah Brooks
reportedly offered to resign but the
Murdochs insisted there was no need I am
satisfied that Rebecca her leadership of
this business and her standard of ethics
and her standard of conduct throughout
her career are very good but as the
pressure grew even David Cameron wants a
friend wanted her out it's been reported
that she offered her resignation over
this and in this situation I would have
taken it on paper her career reads
remarkably well at 21 Rebekah Brooks
joined the news of the world working as
a secretary before becoming a feature
writer for its sunday magazine in 1998
she moved to the Sun where she was
appointed its deputy editor she then
returned to the news of the world in
2000 as editor at the time the youngest
person to head a national British
newspaper three years later she was back
at the Sun becoming the papers first
female editor a role that landed her at
the center of the phone hacking
investigation just the one element of
whether you ever pay the police for
information
we have paid the police and for
information in the past it's been and
will you do it in the future today
operate within the code room within the
law if there's a clear public interest
in within the same same house for a
private detectives for subterfuge for
video bags whatever you want to talk
about it's illegal to police officers do
you see diamonds no no we don't i just
said within the law the questions didn't
stop when she became chief executive of
news international she always denied
knowledge of any illegal behavior but
her defiance did little to dampen the
backlash a backlash that's cost her her
job and left rupert murdoch with an
awkward gap in his media empire laura
boondock Sky News